[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
my guest today is general stanley a
mcchrystal
who is general mcchrystal a
transformational leader with a
remarkable record of achievement general
stanley a mcchrystal was called quote
one of america's greatest warriors end
quote by secretary of defense robert
gates having held leadership and staff
positions in the army special forces
army rangers 82nd airborne division the
18th army airborne corps and the joint
staff mcchrystal became commander of
jsoc in 2003 responsible for leading the
nation's deployed military
counterterrorism efforts around the
globe his leadership is credited with
the 2003 capture of saddam hussein and
the 2006 locating and killing of abu
musab al-zarqawi the leader of al-qaeda
in iraq in june 2009 mcchrystal received
his fourth star and assumed command of
all international forces in afghanistan
general mcchrystal founded them a
crystal group in january 2011 an
advisory services firm that helps
businesses challenge the hierarchical
command and control approach to
organizational management he is a senior
fellow at yale university's jackson
institute for global affairs where he
teaches a course on leadership and he is
the author of the best-selling
leadership books my share of the task a
memoir team of teams new rules of
engagement for a complex world and
leaders myth and reality his newest book
is risk subtitle a user's guide you can
find him online at mcchrystalgroup.com
that is m c c h r y s t a l group dot
com and you can also find the crystal
podcast which started last year and that
is called no turning back
general crystal welcome back to the show
it's good to see you sir oh tim please
call me stan and it's a pleasure
i am so thrilled to have you back on
this is i think round three if we count
the follow-up q a episode and a
tremendous amount has happened
both in the world and in both of our
lives since we last spoke and i wanted
to start with
afghanistan and i'm looking at a
paragraph that i pulled from an older
interview this is from the financial
times with you and you're giving a tour
i believe of your home to the journalist
and you pointed out a map and you said
this is a hand-drawn map of kabul by
british officers from 1842 this is the
route they took to jalalabad one guy
made it out of 15 000. i keep it on my
desk in afghanistan as a reminder let's
not be too sanguine
and i wanted to begin with the current
day everyone has seen so much news about
afghanistan and i can only look at it
personally through the lens of a lay
person with very minimal understanding
having never been there
what do you see when you look at recent
events
if i may ask such a broad question i
think naturally i look at it probably
two ways
i look at it emotionally
because i see our opponent the taliban
now
running the country and of course
already there are indications that their
regime is going to be very difficult on
parts of the country particularly
females but we'll wait and see how that
develops over time
and then i also look at it as someone
who has been involved at least in the
military part of foreign policy and so
i ask myself what does it mean going
forward
the first thing i'd say is though people
always ask me about what's in the
rearview mirror and they say why did it
come this way
and so i'll touch on that and i'll say
that there's a temptation to
oversimplify to find out the critical
mistake the wrong decision the evil
policymaker
the
unaccepted reality and that sort of the
graveyard of empires and to say this is
why it didn't come out the way we wanted
it to and i think that when we do that
we do two things one we miss many other
factors but we also let ourselves off
the hook
i personally don't believe that
afghanistan
in what we tried after 2001 was
impossible
i don't believe that the taliban were 10
feet tall i've
seen too many up close
to believe that
what i believe is in fact many of the
things that failed us
was us
it was our
weaknesses in putting together a
coherent
well-coordinated effort over time and
sometimes that involved
mistakes in decision-making or
half-hearted policies
but often it was just not being able to
make the team of teams work
and that's frustrating because someone
goes to the doctor and wants to know why
they're suffering a certain pain or
malady and the doctor says well you're
in poor health you smoke too much you
drink too much you don't sleep you don't
work out you got all these things
correct those and many of these other
things will not happen
and yet we don't like that advice
we'd rather say well here's the pill or
the procedure i will do to solve that
problem
and so i think afghanistan was as much a
case of us needing to look in the mirror
and say
why do we struggle with big efforts like
that as anything else
what do you think it means
looking forward when you're looking at
the windshield instead of at the
rearview mirror i actually think the
implications are are quite large tim and
the first is
our nation's inability to do big things
like this
and it will undermine our confidence to
take on efforts and there are many we
shouldn't but there may be some we
should
and yet we will be averse to doing that
because we will lack the confidence in
our ability to pull things together and
execute well
maybe the other side of that coin is the
world will look at us that way
most people of my generation who
was born after the second world war
enjoyed a very distinct
environment for our nation where people
may disagree with things the united
states did but there was this
extraordinary respect for our capability
in many cases for our accomplishments
i think that has worn thin i think in
fact
we can't assume we have the same level
of credibility walking into any
situation that we did
even a few years ago
we will have to rebuild that credibility
over time and it will it will take a
significant effort
thank you for answering that it's been
on my mind and a number of my friends
who are veterans
have texted with me about the events
which have been very uh disheartening to
many people who served so i really am
grateful for you shedding some light on
your perspectives since it's it would be
only guesswork on my part
let's jump straight to it and i do this
very rarely i very rarely jump to the
new book usually there's a lot of
background we have though had previous
conversations we've talked a lot about
your history we've talked about
everything from your one meal a day
policy
for yourself not for everyone else to
exercise to training and we'll perhaps
refer back to some of those and in fact
i'll start with a reflection
i was looking back at a recap
of our first ever conversation on the
podcast
and
i asked you and this will tie into risk
i think because most things tie into
risk in some fashion i asked you how you
would train 100 athletes to become
well as my team put it here soldiers and
the athletic part was simply to
check off the box of physical
prerequisites and the answer as it was
paraphrased for me here is that given
that they have all the basic technical
skills you would push them in endurance
live fire training and in making
decisions with incomplete information
decisions through which they would be
forced into bad outcomes and have to
deal with those bad outcomes
and
that last portion is extremely
interesting to me because certainly the
last year has highlighted
how
difficult it is for most people if not
all people in some circumstances to make
decisions with incomplete information
and i spend a lot of time
thinking about risk and mitigating risk
and even just defining risks so could
you maybe start with how you define or
think about risk and why
write an entire book
called risk a user's guide
i hit a point in my life
i'm 67 now
where much of my life i had been
experiencing risk trying to deal with it
trying to mitigate it in some cases
trying to avoid it in other cases
and watching other leaders do the same
and i came to the conclusion we don't do
it very well we've never really done it
very well we had
matrices and calculations that we used
but at the end of the day most of the
decisions were pretty subjective
and they weren't made on data they were
made on
sometimes experience and sometimes just
we'll call it good feel
and our outcomes were
uneven at best
and i came to the conclusion that
the greatest risk that we face
is in fact us
if we're worried about the risks in the
world we should go look in the mirror
because most of the other risks we can't
do anything about they are external
risks that will inevitably emerge
they will be impossible to predict with
great clarity
either in the timing or exact nature of
them
but we can absolutely be confident that
they will show up
and they will impact us and unless we're
extraordinarily fortunate or
nimble we won't dodge them completely
we'll be impacted by them in some way
and we'll have to make decisions based
on that
and so when i talked about preparing
athletes to be a team a world-class team
or to be soldiers in combat
i start with is the absolute assumption
that risks will emerge that will be have
to be dealt with and the impact of those
risks will be at first unclear to people
but they will have to make decisions in
the moment that in themselves carry risk
and so what i mean is there's a risk
emerging
making a decision carries risk as well
it carries reputational risk it carries
potential costs a leader in combat often
has to decide to do things which may
carry significant costs and casualties
from their force
now the desire is to wait until you have
perfect information
so that you don't do something that that
turns out to be ineffective but of
course we all know that not making
or delaying a decision
is a decision in itself and carries its
own risks
unfortunately we have habits which often
say that
the person who actively makes a decision
and goes a certain direction and has a
bad outcome or it is costly is held
accountable but someone who doesn't make
decisions
we don't hold them to the same account
we sort of say well they didn't make
decisions
and so
they're not really responsible i found
in the counter-terrorist world we used
to get opportunities arise and
you call it a certain terrorists would
be located somewhere we have the
opportunity to arrest or to target them
and we have to get a decision and some
of those decisions would have to go all
the way up to the highest levels in dc
and so what you do is you go to
decision makers and went through a
series of levels
and often part way through that some
decision maker bureaucrat in the system
would go well let me ask a couple
questions how much wood can a wood chuck
chuck
and i go
and i'd go what are you talking about
there are no wood chucks in this and
they'd say well i need to have more
information before i can improve it and
so we'd go back and we'd find out how
much would a can show you we come back
by that time
the opportunity had passed
and what happened was that decision
maker would then look at me and say damn
it stan
i wanted to improve that you need to
come better prepared so i can approve it
and what they had really done
is they hadn't accepted the risk of
approving a mission
they hadn't accepted
the responsibility for disapproving
they'd sidestepped it
and they had the effect of preventing
us in doing anything
and i don't know how many different
permutations of that i've seen
but the idea that we want to mitigate
risk to zero before we act
is really common and really costly
you know i was looking back
at the notes from that first episode
that i mentioned and
the
second part to that answer a bit later
on
with respect to the hypothetical
training of 100 athletes
was
and again paraphrasing
indicating that what you're looking for
is largely that the commanders were
reflective and not just making knee-jerk
decisions there's no right answer
necessarily in those situations just a
more thoughtful way of arriving at the
answer right and this is something that
i see a lot also in the best investors
in the world who i've i've been lucky
enough to to interview or spend time
with and that is
they have to be very careful about
separating process from outcome so that
they are rewarding good process even if
you happen to pull a joker card and get
a bad outcome
and vice versa right not rewarding bad
process just because somebody happened
to pull the ace of spades out of the
deck by sheer luck
how did you think about organizing
risk a user's guide and actually
formatting
the book to to teach people to
systematically
think about risk in a smarter way or
perhaps a more informed way
we started by looking at what risk
really is and of course most of us think
of risk is that intersection between the
probability of event occurring and the
consequences if it does
and if the consequences are low or if
the probability is low we don't worry
about it if both rise up and suddenly we
we take notice and we try to do
something to mitigate it
you can also think of risks slightly
differently as a mathematical equation
and you say that mathematical equation
is
what is the threat
and what is your vulnerability to that
threat
and literally it's threat times
vulnerability equals your risk so
if the threat to me is somebody with a
handgun
and i am walking down the street and
they want to shoot me
and that handgun would hurt me
i've got pretty high level of risk
if however i'm in a tank
and they have a handgun
then suddenly my vulnerability is much
reduced
and so the resulting risk and if my
vulnerability is zero my risk is zero so
if i can either reduce the threat to
zero
or the vulnerability to zero i've taken
it to zero now very rarely can we do
zero in either
but we don't control the threats much we
do control our vulnerabilities
we control what can hurt us and what we
can do about it in the moment
so we started to think about
risk
acting with risk is really about
reducing your vulnerabilities
think of the human immune system and
this was the analogy that
that jumped out at us the human immune
system fights off something like 10 000
pathogens a day
which could make us sick or kill us
and we don't think anything about it
because when we're normally healthy it
just detects assess responds and learns
from that process and we go on our merry
way
if our immune system is weakened because
we're sick or with an autoimmune
deficiency
suddenly those things which wouldn't
bother us
on a daily basis become potentially very
dangerous
and so if we start to think about that
then the reality is every one of us as
individuals and every organization has
the equivalent of an immune system
which is either healthy
or it is not healthy and we could call
it a risk immune system and that's in
the book we we offer a model in which
there are 10 factors or risk control
factors
and those risk control factors such as
communication
narrative
timing
action bias diversity are all components
of how well you
and your organization are able
to detect risks
assess their danger potential threat to
you respond to them and learn from that
and so the trick
is to understand those risk control
factors
strengthen those
as both individual factors and as a
system
and keep yourself as healthy because
you're accepting the reality that you
can't prevent all the threats from
emerging
i would love to delve into the world of
stories maybe case studies and this may
be a way of tying some of your previous
work to this as well or you could pull
from the new book you wrote a book as
mentioned in the intro leaders myth and
reality and this was a plutarchian study
of various leaders 13 case studies
ranging from coco chanel to abu musab
al-zarqawi including walt disney many
others
are there any of those leaders
or other leaders who come to mind who
have exhibited
intelligence or excellent execution
around
risk are there any stories that you
might tell
that would pull together some of the
concepts we're discussing or just a
general story about someone who's
excellent at
interacting with or thinking about risk
the unexpected one is coco chanel
and of course she was born in the late
part of the 19th century of modest
upbringing her father essentially
deserted her when she was young says she
grew up as a de facto orphan
she had
if you look at it no opportunities
and she was probably going to be
relegated to not much in life
and yet she became initially a nightclub
singer
and a courtesan you might call it
and she
she ingratiated herself with some people
who had more money and so she got an
opportunity and partly was her physical
charms and her willingness to use them
but then on the other part the risk
there is she becomes minimalized she
becomes personally a commodity
and she wasn't going to accept that and
so what she wanted to do was create
an identity and an opportunity for
herself that was beyond that
and so she did an amazing thing first
she designs an entirely new line of
fashion
and she intersects with the period when
simpler fashions during the first world
war the costs and whatnot were
accepted but she also becomes the brand
herself
she decides to transform herself
into the walking embodiment of the
lifestyle her fashions
are designed to sell a little like ralph
lauren did a couple of generations after
that
and so
the risks to her were overwhelming and
of course as as a female gets older the
idea that a female is going to be able
to still be a fashion icon is is
non-traditional because typically it's
for a young period when they are very
physically attractive but instead what
she did was she became
iconic first as a fashion icon herself
and then there's a power in the industry
developing
you know channel number five becoming a
uh a business tycoon that's the only way
we can say it and so
you know that one jumps out at me the
other person who is probably unexpected
is dr martin luther king jr
because when dr king
led the civil rights movement
you think well obviously there's
opposition from entrenched forces the
whites in the south
didn't want progress but in reality
what he realized the risks to the civil
rights movement were really wide and
we'll call him diverse
when he wrote his famous letter from a
birmingham jail he was actually
criticizing moderate national white
clergy
who had said dr king we agree
with the aims of the civil rights
movement but you're too aggressive
you're pushing too hard
and he understood that the real risk to
the civil rights movement
was not the very
impassioned violent
response from sheriff clarke in alabama
in fact it was inaction
it was passive
support from the rest of white america
and so dr king understood those risks
and what he had to do was take him on
with a
campaign that went the entire breadth
he had to campaign not just against
those entrenched george wallace-like
interests he had to campaign against the
people who lived far away from the deep
south and yet who support politically
was essential to the civil rights
movement things like the voting rights
act having an opportunity and to
convince presidents kennedy and then
johnson that it was in their political
interest
to take political risk to push something
that was important to dr king in the
civil rights movement so his
understanding of
risk to his movement and how to put
other people at risk
almost like a chess master
so that he could maneuver them into
support was
was pretty impressive and when we think
of dr king as a great orator saying i
have a dream
and we leave him two-dimensional then i
think we miss a master strategist
those are two
outstanding and very unexpected
different ways in different ways
unexpected examples so thank you very
much for that
you know i'd love to just mention
something for people listening and that
is
defining risk for yourself is extremely
extremely extremely important if i could
just
kind of pontificate on this for a second
because
if you don't define it it can end up
being this very vague hazy
sort of specter that affects you but is
untreatable i loved your if i'm
recalling it correctly sort of threat
times vulnerability as an example of
that you know for myself i've often
thought about risk as the likelihood of
an irreversible negative outcome just
from the investing and business
perspective right so you have
for instance walt disney since i just
mentioned walt disney i was listening to
a case study of walt disney
and the company and the fact that
walt disney and company it effectively
and please correct me if i'm getting
this wrong but
been a break-even proposition at best up
until snow white which changed
everything and it was a huge investment
but it also returned the entire
fund so to speak it made up for all the
losses and of course it's a hits driven
business so as long as you can
afford
the potential of it being a failure
investing the amount of money necessary
to test the new technology then allowed
them to recreate and reinvent and
ultimately build this empire of a
company
and i would love to hear any other
examples that come to mind another one
just to
riff because i've had enough caffeine
this morning is jeff bezos and uh we
don't spend too much time on chef bezos
but i was reading a story about one of
their product failures and i think it
was i want to say the fire phone
and at the press conference i'm
paraphrasing all this i might get some
of the details wrong but he said in
effect oh just wait we're going to have
much bigger failures
because uh from those
experiments ultimately he had confidence
with his team with the methodologies
that they would create incredible
successes like prime which was
very much doubted and kind of ridiculed
in the early days and of course it's
it's it's become something quite
different are there any other stories
that you might be able to share of
leaders they don't have to be well known
they could be
who have exhibited good
thinking or behavior
around risk
i i'd start a little bit back with uh
walt disney because you are correct he
in fact mortgaged mickey mouse
to fund snow white
i did not know yeah the intellectual
property of mickey mouse he mortgaged
him so that he could make the movie snow
white
um but risks continue to change so walt
disney of course is wildly successful
with snow white it
changes full-length animated movies in
fact it was the first movie and he said
i can make audiences cry as well as
laugh and once he learned they could do
that of course we we have the whole
library of disney movies now
but is the company changed
he went through a number of crisis
points early in the second world war he
had a labor struggle inside his firm
and the company was evolving and
walt disney began to understand he was
not the right guy to run it
and so the walt disney of when i was a
child and i watched the wonderful world
of color and uncle walt would come on
and introduce davy crockett was now
focused on things which were his
strength like development of disneyland
and then disney world and his brother
roy
in fact took over much of the running of
the business
because they had come to the conclusion
that
the risks had changed the requirement
had changed and the risk had changed so
walt disney was much more
effective in focusing on those things
that were his strengths and his interest
as opposed to trying to do something for
which she's not you know really well
suited
if we think about
decisions in risk and i'm a a big fan of
annie duke the poker player
and for sure
she will talk a lot about probabilities
as you mentioned tim
you got to separate the decision from
the outcome
and let's go to afghanistan again for a
moment because everybody is very upset
about the withdrawal from afghanistan
and
the reality is
had the taliban not moved quickly
and toppled the government and american
forces had come out quickly and been
gone before the government of
afghanistan fell
it might be viewed as a brilliant stroke
you know people have different opinions
on the wisdom of the the overall but
that particular outcome of that decision
might be viewed entirely differently
because the outcome what you've really
got to do in my view on a decision is go
back to two factors the first is are
they making the decision with the right
values in mind
are they using integrity and the things
that represent you as an individual and
you as an organization and then the
second is it a rational decision
probability wise what they know then
there's an interesting analysis to go
back to the japanese admiral who was
defeated at the battle of midway and
there's the famous moment when he makes
a decision
to re-arm his planes and he re-arms his
planes and during that process the
american dive bombers come in and
destroy three aircraft carriers in a
matter of minutes and change the course
of the war
and we step back and we go oh look at
that japanese admiral he just didn't
have his act together and whatnot but if
you analyze the information he had in
the moment
and each decision as he made over time
they were completely rational in fact
they probably would be the decisions you
or i would make and so when we go back
to look at it and we get so fixated on
the outcome
because it didn't work it must have been
stupid
then we don't teach ourselves how to do
risk management and decision making
because in reality
you may make a number of decisions that
don't work out well but as you mentioned
jeff bezos as he's building a stronger
team and he makes some decisions that
don't work
one they are learning from those
decisions two as the team gets stronger
he knows that the probability of success
over time is continuing to rise
and so our argument in our book is as
you continue to strengthen
your organization's risk immune system
your probability of success in every
endeavor goes up
because you are healthy you are more
able to accept the really bad piece of
luck
because when probability evens out over
time you're in a stronger position
and the threat times vulnerability
equals risk is really important on a
multitude of levels of course because if
either side is too big a number and the
other side isn't zero you have a large
problem on your hands and if you look at
andy duke poker i think her book is
thinking in bets if i'm recalling
correctly or you look at say a book like
bringing down the house
by ben metric which was about this team
from mit who had a system for winning in
blackjack
you can have the best system in the
world but you also have to have in this
particular case enough bankroll enough
money to sustain an extended string of
bad
and i would love to
jump to the 10 risk control factors one
jumped out that i'd love to hear you
speak more about and that is if i'm
recalling correctly narrative or
narratives would you mind expanding on
that
narrative is what we say about ourselves
and it's how we want to be defined
we begin in the book with the story of
the alamo and william barrett buck
travis stands out in the courtyard of
the alimony draws the line in the sand
and he tells whoever will stay with me
for victory or death we will defend the
alamo and of course history says
everybody came across the line
and the reality was the alamo was
tactically operationally strategically
insignificant
it bought a little bit of time for sam
houston to build up the army but the
reality is it did not matter much
but in terms of narrative
remember the alamo became a call
across texas and actually that's
infected across the united states
of resolute people
absolutely committed to win their
independence and so
the alamo becomes important all out of
proportion to its scale of the fight
itself and so the narrative becomes the
story it is the power
a little like the 300 spartans or david
and goliath the reality is the story
becomes
the thing
and so
the narrative becomes very
very powerful for an organization think
when we believe in the narrative we
think we believe the narrative of the
united states we touched a little bit
earlier about the potential that our
credibility could be weakened suddenly
the narrative that the united states
having the kind of values that should
prevail in the world and the power
to prevail in the world they go hand in
hand if we look at a case where they get
at cross purposes
google is a
tremendous case in point in reality
google started
the idea of don't be evil and what i
remember when i first saw it i said boy
that's a really catchy idea and who
couldn't be for don't be evil
and then you say well what does don't be
evil mean well it's a little bit in the
eye of the beholder
but it's still generally powerful we're
gonna do good things
and then in 2017
when google started working with the
defense department on project maven some
of the people inside google felt like
that was
in opposition to the narrative in
opposition to don't be evil and the
culture in google was that everybody
would be googly and speak up
and have their say and help shape the
culture and they had a very serious
crisis on their hands because a number
of people in the company felt like the
leadership had lost their way and was
violating the narrative and so we call
that a say do gap the difference between
what we say
and then what we actually do
and so the power of narrative
it's critical that we have one
but it's also critical that we
understand what it is and that we be
true to it
and if we're not prepared to be true to
it we should change it
we should reflect what it really is
as you discuss narrative i can't help
think about
a few things number one is how much our
individual and collective realities are
governed by these stories of course
and also the
the incredible power and damage that can
be done
when your software
that's being installed is a story not of
your choosing in a sense and so i'd love
to ask you
about the power or risks of propaganda
and misinformation
that
seem to be coming more and more
prevalent certainly
with the amplification
of technology and sort of ubiquitous
social media
and so on but could you speak to that if
you have any particular thoughts yeah i
personally think it may be the biggest
threat to american society today and
that is true in many other societies as
well
if we go back to just the power of
information of what we believe
we fall in line behind certain
narratives either a patriotism or
identity of the organization we're a
part of
and they're critical but we also listen
to information that comes and influences
us we are all
influenced by advertising we're
influenced by
slogans
we look at of course the master adolf
hitler who created an entire idea that
germany had to come back into the world
after the first world war in a proud and
strong way and then he pushed a number
of ideas that were of course much more
extreme than that
but he was adolf hitler was still
popular in germany the day he was killed
in 1945.
now that's unthinkable because after 12
years of essentially taking his nation
of war and destroying it
germans still believed in him because
the power of the message
was so
it was almost like a narcotic and we say
well that could never happen to us
well let's look at
tobacco in america
back in the 1940s and 50s it became
clear
that tobacco was a carcinogenic
and nicotine was of course highly
addictive
and as that information started to
become really logically irrefutable
the american tobacco institute which was
funded by big tobacco
implemented a very clever campaign and
they didn't take on the idea they didn't
say no tobacco doesn't cause cancer
what they said is tobacco may cause
cancer
they left a little bit of daylight and
they left each person who wanted to
smoke
they left them daylight to say well it
may cause cancer but it may not
and the american cancer institute played
this over and over enough doubt
so that people could continue to market
cigarettes people could continue to
smoke people could argue about that
and we realized how vulnerable
we are
to
either blatant misinformation
you know what one side calls the big lie
but also to very subtle misinformation
which
much of it is true and suddenly we start
to believe things
and act on those
if we look at the state of the american
political environment right now
we've got a polarization that is as
stark as i think we've seen since right
before the civil war
and there were strong economic causes
for it then and we don't have the same
root causes
now pulling us apart now they are more
tribal
they are more cultural they are more
informational
and the ability to have our mind shaped
if i was in tech right now if i was a
big tech leader and we were talking
about risks
i would get up in the morning and i'd
say i may have created the thing that is
going to destroy my firm
meaning if i am in social media i may
have created
a suicide machine because that which
they have created is so damaging
that in fact
there will be a
a revulsion
against what is happening to our young
people and to a degree to ourselves
and so i think that if tech leaders
don't get in front of this
and start to understand it i could argue
the same may be true of artificial
intelligence as we start to employ it
more and we understand the impacts
i think that leaders have got to
understand
that the actual risk to them
may be now in failing to get in front of
it
and act on that now and shape it so that
it is not as damaging as
uh it can otherwise be
i have to
just
raise my hand and
concur 100 percent with that and there's
so many
different threats let's just say
threats that people might consider
existential threats and
the discussion of
tech and say social media inputs and the
behaviors that are reinforced by those
technologies
and the belief systems that are also
created and reinforced i find absolutely
terrifying and i say that as someone who
has let's just call it a monthly
audience of somewhere between 15 and 20
million people
and many of these listeners and readers
are consistent so i'm able to see
changes in behavior over time
and the collective changes and
individual changes i mean i recognize a
lot of these names now i mean hundreds
and thousands of people who have been in
my communities for many years the degree
of polarity and rage
that i've seen in
mass numbers of people in whom i
couldn't see those characteristics
earlier is really mind-boggling so i i
have to agree with you
jim can we talk about that in
relation to covet yes please
because
if we think about kovid it was almost
the perfect enemy
and i say it was perfect because it was
inanimate
so it was okay to hate covet you didn't
have to have any sympathy for kovit
and so it was like out of a movie if
aliens had come from outer space the
entire world could righteously unite to
fight that
now we have that it wasn't from outer
space but it was that
and so we have this emerging threat that
could and should have united us
extraordinarily well
and our first excuse is we say well we
were surprised we didn't see it coming
and the reality is although we didn't
know covet 19 would come we absolutely
knew
that another viral infection that could
be a pandemic would come because they
have come with frightening regularity in
history
so its appearance was inevitable
and then the second thing is we
absolutely knew what to do about it the
science of public health is pretty good
and so we knew what works and what
doesn't work
and then we literally got a scientific
miracle because
they were able to produce vaccines at a
speed never contemplated before and
almost a freebie so if you line those
all up
and we had even done an exercise in 2019
inside the united states crimson
contagion to war game this and we had
wargamed a viral infection coming from
china
beginning in chicago and us struggling
with it so we had war gamed a pretty
painful outcome and then when covet 19
arrived what did we do globally
we acted
as individual nations
what did we do nationally
we froze to a great degree at the
national level for a period we had
problems with our narrative
then we executed
at least on the state level but i could
argue we were even more atomized than
that many cases we operated at a
municipal level
and no
organization at that level has the
resources or the ability to effectively
fight a pandemic by itself it has to be
a united effort
it actually has to be a global united
effort
so
my point is
our vulnerability was self-induced to
covet 19.
covet 19 like the taliban is not 10 feet
tall it's
imminently defeatable
and so what we should do is we should
say we failed as a system
we can't look for a single person who
screwed this up and pin the tail on them
we failed as a system and that should
worry us
because where we fail as a system means
the next threat that arises
means our system has already proven its
limitation and we better look at that
system
i was just thinking about this last
night probably because i had this
conversation on my mind and
i was thinking a few things
of course the death toll is atrocious we
are not fully out of the woods
the numbers also i think have just not
had the psychological impact
that other events like 911 would have
because like you said it's this
invisible intangible in some ways
abstract also long-term death toll but
imagine if we had been hit with delta
first or imagine if we were
hit in 2000 who knows let's just make it
pretty recent 2005 2010 when
we had fewer technologies that would
allow people to work remotely and what
the impact would have been on the
economy
in a sense i mean we are having
and did get a very important dress
rehearsal because it's not going to be
the last pandemic or
nationwide perhaps even global
catastrophe that we have to contend with
do you feel like we have improved or
fixed some of these systems or addressed
any of the systematic
failures to be better prepared for next
time would you imagine that we have
tim i was on two commissions last year
one from accounts from farm relations
which
explored this question and came up with
recommendations and then another from an
organization called the business
executives for national service and both
of those commissions were formed of
really smart accomplished people in me
and i was put on sort of for comic
relief
we fixed a few things
but the reality is
most of the things we fix which are
systemic in nature
our communications how we coordinate
these things how decisions are made
how we resource the different
requirements for public health
i think have been woefully
under
addressed so far
i think one of the things that you
notice or that you mentioned is just so
important
we had the ability enabled by technology
to continue on many things we do
many businesses could continue to
operate generally
actually i think part of that is
unfortunate
part of it's it's wonderful it's a
miracle because our economy didn't
completely disappear
but you know if our economy was not able
to limp along at first and then to come
back like it has
we would have been forced
into more decisive
activities against covet 19
because we could essentially push much
of the suffering onto parts of our
population
people like you and i who might have the
opportunity to work from home and what
we do can be enabled by that
we didn't have to do things which i
think might have forced us to address
those vulnerabilities
and i think that may be
a long-term
challenge for us
because if something isn't bad enough
you don't fix the problem if people come
out of covet 19 thinking well
you know if we only lose 600 000 people
you know i didn't know many of them
anyway so it's okay
that's a problem
yeah that is a problem
what do you think it will take for
things to be fixed is it going to
require
something like something of the scale of
another pandemic with even worse
outcomes to
force the hand or do you feel like there
are things that can be done to
catalyze those changes in the meantime
i know their things can be done and most
of them have been identified i am not
confident we will do them i think on the
margins we are doing some things
certainly and we're getting smarter and
so
part of that will happen but i would
pull us to cyber security
we have a very similar situation with
cyber security right now that we do with
pandemics because
a huge cyber security challenge is
inevitable
it's not possible it is inevitable and
when i talk about huge i'm not talking
about
target having
some customer data exposed i'm talking
about things that we rely on stopping
for at least a period maybe it's banking
maybe it's our energy distribution
things like that
i think it's absolutely inevitable that
that will happen
and the question is
will we address it before
that happens on a big way
we have not yet we have done a number of
things but this requires a public
private partnership on a level we've
never had before between the government
and big corporations because cyber
security isn't something that you put a
big cyber security defensive maginot
line at the nation's borders it's not
like that
cyber security is something that is
in-depth it's built into all of our
systems and it also has to be built into
our culture
of how we operate and what private
security and liberties we were willing
to have shaped to get greater security
and so i think where we are is we're
extraordinarily vulnerable but we are
to a certain degree have our heads in
the sand hoping that they'll get
somebody else i think many businesses
right now get up every morning and and
know that they could be the target
and they're happy if somebody else
gets hit
[Music]
i have so many follow-up questions we
spoke with this in one of our prior
conversations but i think it's a concept
worth revisiting
and that is the concept of
the red team or red teaming
would you mind just describing what that
is because i think it's even as a
thought exercise and sometimes it's
difficult to take on both parts as a
single person because you're too close
to your systems too close to your
problems but
would you mind describing what a red
team is
it's essentially making somebody the bad
guy and commissioning them to screw you
up
and you say well why would i do that
because we become blind to our
vulnerabilities there's a great story
from a war game called millennium
challenge which happened before the
first gulf war and a
a marine general named van reiper a
lieutenant general was
made the commander of the opposition
essentially in a red team role and
he looked at
how this was likely to play out because
he was playing a mideast nation and so
he said i'm not going to let the
americans do what they're good at
i'm going to do a pre-emptive strike and
so he did a preemptive strike and he in
the game he killed the equivalent of 20
000 americans and he really screwed up
the american plan and so they stopped
the war game
and they recocked and went back and they
said okay we're going to continue but
don't do that again
and it was like wait a minute
the whole idea of a red team is to find
clever people
who will come and find the holes in your
plan
where are there gaps and seams or flaws
that you have become blind to
where will they as you inflate you know
it's that tire inner tube that you've
been working on and you patched you
inflate it and you see if there are any
more leaks where are the leaks
a good red team
is people who are a step outside your
organization you can have people inside
but they have to be
fenced off
and so that they are not wedded to the
plan because if they're wedded to the
plan they're incentivized not to find
flaws in it
and so you've really got to have a red
team that's incentivized to find flaws
and then the leadership has got to act
on those when they find those problems
gaps and seems the leadership has got to
follow up and got to close them and they
can't make the red team pariahs they
can't say you know you people are bad
people because you're disloyal to our
plan
no the greatest loyalty you can ever do
is to make it stronger
and so i'm a great believer that red
teaming takes us out of being
comfortable and we're all guilty i
remember as a as a commander in combat
you work a plan for a long time you do
all these things and if somebody
questioned it or poked a hole in it
right when it was time to execute you
got mad
because
damn it we're about to execute this plan
don't don't distract me don't do that
that's that's irritating
but but you need them to do that and so
red teams are really effective way to to
pressure test so when you look at
we could say this country we could speak
globally also but
what threats either most concern you or
which threats do you think people are
not paying enough attention to yeah and
i'll let you define threats and people
as you like
i think not surprisingly i'll tell you
that the one that literally leaves me up
at night is
the failure of our system to be able to
do routine things routinely and what i
talk about is when our government is
seized
up with partisanship
and we are unable to do the normal
functions as outlined in the
constitution
if we're unable to have the normal
political debate to make processes work
without doing up huge pendulum swings to
one side or the other
then
the machine isn't working right as long
as the american government and society
are working we'll get dinged up with
threats that will come but we will
always be able to respond when the
system isn't working
i think we are fundamentally vulnerable
to covet 19 or to potential foreign
aggression or to terrorism cyber
security you pick any number of threats
then there are some
other issues that of course jump out
cyber security of course is the one that
i would spend most of my time worried
about because i think it's immediate
i think that climate change is one of
those cases where
if your neighbor's house was on fire you
would go do something about it
the reality though is if there was a
fire 10 miles away that was burning up
all the fields that produced the food
you eat
it wouldn't be as apparent to you and so
you might not run outside and call the
fire department and i think climate
change is one of those cases where
we are literally destroying that which
we are dependent upon but because it's
not happening
in crisis speed that we think of in fast
rolling
time and it's happening more gradually
it doesn't seem as
as dangerous the problem is the
corrective time is also much slower
so you can't just put out the fire to
your neighbor's house it takes a long
time so climate change and then finally
i would throw out education on a very
national level
if you don't have an educated population
then you're not going to be competitive
internationally because the days of the
united states having this huge
geographic and social advantage are gone
there are so many other places that
educate a lot of young people and now
they they can compete so that's the one
and second if you don't have an educated
population
you get ignorant stuff happening
you know many of the great ills in life
are because people just don't know and
when you are subjected to the kind of
misinformation in our society
you arm people with knowledge you give
them the ability to understand we used
to deal with many people who would come
in as terrorists into afghanistan
and many had been taught in madrasas in
pakistan they'd been taught
the quran and they memorized it but they
didn't speak arabic
so they didn't understand what they were
reading they required the interpretation
of whoever was teaching them and so they
were entirely vulnerable on someone else
telling them what was right or wrong
they couldn't do the critical analysis
because they didn't have the education
for it so as a consequence they became
vulnerable when we are ignorant
we are vulnerable we are ignorant as a
society we are societally vulnerable
let's return to arming with knowledge i
would
love to explore communication a bit it
just seems like the glue the connective
tissue that holds so much together could
you elaborate on your thoughts about the
four tests leaders and teams can use to
evaluate their communication
if we think about communication we say
well i got a cell phone and she's got a
cell phone so we're in communication
no
i think that means you could potentially
communicate
but there are four tests that decide
whether you actually communicate
and the first is
technically
can i get my message to the person or
people that i'm trying to communicate to
can i send a letter write an email or
whatever mode that you need to use can
it get there
the second is more subtle but more often
a big issue it's will i do it will i
communicate my message will i tell the
people in other silos in my company
or in other places will i pass them the
information and it might be i won't pass
them because i don't like them
it might be i don't pass it because
i don't know they exist it might be i
don't pass it because my boss hasn't
given me approval there any number of
reasons not all of which are black and
white evil but the reality is the second
test if you won't pass information there
is no communication
the third starts to be
can the person receive it
can they understand it am i transmitting
in english and they speak chinese
or are they of a mindset that just is
not willing to hear what i'm saying and
then of course the final one that goes
hand in hand with that is what i'm
passing accurate and timely
so am i giving them good information
that would truly be a value and are they
capable of receiving it so if you don't
have a yes on all four tests
you don't really have communication
and if you don't have communication both
ways one you don't know if you're
communicating and two
you can't have the iterative
importance of communication where you
say something to me i process it i talk
back to you and there's a dialectic
which occurs which over time opposing
thoughts start to get to where we can
get to something approaching rational
reality
or logic
with with just me thinking what i think
and jamming it to you we don't get there
and if i can't get it to you it doesn't
happen so it's got to be two ways so
communication and an organization
is really of the 10 risk control factors
we had hours of argument over which was
most important leadership or
communication i think communication is
that our table stakes
if an organization can't communicate
internally or won't
then they can't respond to anything
the human immune system requires the
ability of the body to sense threats
communicate back up whether they are
dangerous and then whether we should do
something about it if we can sense
threats in our society but we can't
communicate we can't do anything about
it
and so
therein lies the challenge
so let's talk about one puzzle piece
within that challenge and that is being
willing to receive
or hear
and
i want to focus on this because i i feel
like
alongside the polarity and the
polarization that we're seeing
in a sea of
propaganda and click bait and so on
online
there's also a
fetishizing of fragility in a sense we
don't have to spend too much time on
that but i do want to spend some time on
the opposite so what i've noticed
certainly in many teams even among
friend groups and so on
there is a hesitancy to
share certain things for fear of
upsetting another person
so ultimately being willing to share is
a negative
for fear that the willing to receive
will not be there
and i'm curious to know if there are any
approaches you've seen that are really
effective for people to train themselves
to become more resilient in being able
to receive candid communication or
helping their teams to become more
resilient and capable of communicating
in a very candid fashion
i would love to hear any and all
thoughts on that
in the military we used to always do
things called after action reviews and
they really started from the second
world war and they came out of the the
realization that after a battle or a
fire fight every participant had a
different view of what had happened
you know you watch a war movie and you
see a firefight you say everybody saw
the same thing no they didn't they all
saw where they were
and they
present an account after the fact that
is very skewed and in many cases it's
skewed from what they saw and then they
just get it wrong so everybody walks
away with a different set of conclusions
to that
and so after action reviews were put in
place to do two things one to figure out
what happened
and then to
figure out what they should do about it
next time to be better so the first part
of that was getting everybody together
and going through and searching for
truth
and figuring trying to pull all the
pieces out and that was frightening to
some people because sometimes you'll
find out that what you thought the
reality was was very different
and then when you start to talk about
what went right and what went wrong
often it can be very very illuminating
to your shortcomings
i remember as a young company commander
we would go into after action reviews
after big training missions and some
would last four hours long and i would
walk out humiliated
because they had using sights and sounds
from the battlefields because they had
pictures and slides and and whatnot
they would point out every one of my
screw-ups and they would not only point
out every one of my scripts they'd do it
in front of all of my peers and my
bosses and my boss's boss
and so they could be very very upsetting
events
and my boss's
weaknesses were also pointed out to all
his subordinates and that was pretty
upsetting as well
so the effort was to create a thick skin
to understand that everybody makes
mistakes
so let's
be open enough to accept those
and to accept
different viewpoints i think what we've
come into now is
a point in society that is
a little bit unhealthy in fact i'm going
to call it more than a little bit
unhealthy i teach at yale university and
i've been there i'm in my 12th year
and i will tell you that the atmosphere
on the campus has continued to evolve
and i don't think for the better
in one sense it's better because there
are
people championing
rights that people should have and
equality and values that i think are are
good
but there is an intolerance
for anyone's whose values are different
than yours
in fact there's an unwillingness to
listen to a speaker from outside the
university come and speak that might
have a polar opposite position
we talked a little while ago about that
the importance of the dialectic
where you get opposing ideas together
and if you only hear what you already
believe or if you protect yourself
from the offensive words
of somebody who
who violates your safe space
then i think you are making yourself
more vulnerable over time
i absolutely believe we need to as a
society
subject ourselves to all of this
constantly but we need to build up the
resilience in that process to hear it to
tolerate it to understand that things
like the first amendment had a purpose
to them
they were to protect people's rights to
communicate but they were also to build
up in society
a diverse dialogue
that would produce a good outcome for
democracy and so
i think it's important when we talk
about communication now to understand
that
it's not just what you want to
communicate or just what you want to
hear
it's got to be sometimes what we need to
hear
are there any other
ways
that you
suggest or that you found to be
effective for training resilience that
are applicable in the civilian sphere
there are a number of things that can
make an organization communicate more or
be
systemically but there's nothing like
failure to train resilience
i remember when i was a ranger
regimental commander we put in place an
exercise which we call savage strike if
i remember correctly and we would take a
ranger company about 150 rangers and we
would take them from their home base and
we'd put them in airplanes and we'd fly
them halfway across the country and
they'd do a parachute assault to go do
this mission and the mission typically
was something like this they'd have to
go from the drop zone where they landed
in parachutes to go rescue a number of
americans who were being threatened in
an area in some country and they would
get there and we would orchestrate
opposing forces and whatnot role players
so that when they got there they would
secure the americans and they would be
moving to extract them and then the
enemy would attack and when the enemy
attacked they would cause a number of
casualties in the ranger force that
would always be the dynamic now the
ranger company commander's in a position
where the mission
he was given was to extract the american
civilians
but the ethos of the rangers is i will
never leave a falling comrade to fall
into the hands of the enemy
so this ranger company commander is in
this position where to extract the
americans he's got to leave his dead and
wounded
to leave his dead and wounded he's got
to violate the very oath the very being
of being a ranger and so i would play
the higher headquarters and the company
commander would invariably
call in with this
situation report and say here's the
problem
and i'd say okay
get the american citizens out and they
go sir i can't because i've got my dead
wounded i can't leave them
uh i need reinforcements and i said well
you're not getting reinforcements i
can't i got nobody to send you
and so they'd be in this it was really a
moral dilemma as well as an operational
dilemma for which there was no right
answer
and
they would get beat up and we would go
and have a detailed after-action review
better and they'd always say well what
was the approved solution and my
response was i don't know
you know you tell me but we're gonna be
in those positions because
we've got to be resilient enough one to
fail
and two to make those damnably
impossible decisions where you're doing
something you just hate doing
to do something you have to do
and so they were torn between do i fail
in a mission or do i essentially break
my oath
i have to just interrupt for a second to
ask you about the assessments so after
putting
someone in a position like that
what are you looking for because there
there may be no right answer but are you
looking for speed of execution and logic
slash rationale behind the decision what
are you looking for what are the
positive indicators
because there's no perfect answer what i
was looking for was first does that
person
keep cool and go through a process
do they first try to to get external
things to help them out of it like
asking for reinforcements because that's
logical so you do that until you narrow
down okay we've got this really
difficult situation and i've got to do a
or b
then i'm looking at how their values fit
in
and their values in some cases or
honesty and loyalty to people and then
the other is
did they go through a rational
probability based
outcome did they say this is the best i
think we can do here
our likelihood of this being successful
etc
because you're really looking for
someone whose mind continues to function
when things aren't the way they want
them to be
because they were to be honest there
were a couple cases where the commander
almost just said screw it
everybody we're gonna do a custom we're
just gonna fight and die
and and they were almost
angry
they said we shouldn't have been in this
position screw it we're gonna fight and
die the hell with it and
that may be the right answer but that
wasn't the right way it was arrived at
right you know i wanted them to stay
calm and be thinking and look for
options and then say all right this is
the best of lousy courses of action and
go from there
it raises so many questions for me
related to
how someone could sort of mock that in
i'm not saying they should but this is
the idea that comes to mind sort of mock
that in an interview scenario if you're
trying to vet for important positions in
in a company you know how do you
navigate a stressful situation and do
you ask them because i know there's a
lot of criticism of stress interviews
also
where you ask someone open a window and
the windows jammed or whatever it might
be right some of those could probably
end up being pretty foolish but
is it enough to ask someone about how
they've handled the situation like that
or do you really need to kind of put
them into a situation like that
in a civilian setting i'm just
having that run through my head i don't
know if it's even feasible to to do that
but it seems like an incredibly powerful
way to
reveal character and behavior under
stress have you seen
any version of that implemented outside
of the military i have heard about it
outside of the military but
you know it's hard in many cases but i
i'm a great believer in role playing
things one of the things i try to see
whether it's in an interview or in
someone's performance after in the
organization when they're put in those
decisions do they try to dodge them can
they find a way to not be responsible
there's the famous story of course of
admiral rickover the father of the
nuclear navy and his decision-making or
his interview process
reportedly he put people in a chair and
the two front legs of the chair were
shorter than the back legs
so when you sat down you automatically
were sliding off the chair so
so you had to fight to stay on and then
he would do these
really combative
interviews where he would basically ask
why were you born you're not you know
worth it and he asked one candidate
all right you've got two minutes to make
me angry
and apparently the guy got up to the
admiral's desk where there was a model
of the first nuclear aircraft carrier he
picked it up and smashed it
on the floor
and the uh reportedly the admiral says
okay you did it
you accomplish that
but but i do think there's an awful lot
to creating cases where people are under
some kind of simulated pressure one they
they learn an awful lot about themselves
yeah for sure as well as you learning
about them
yeah it's chatting with with someone i
do work with he works with a lot of
executives who are hiring and sometimes
he's brought in as he put it to be the
loving [ __ ] who can apply a little
bit of pressure to see what happens
nothing too terrible nothing too extreme
but just to see how do they handle a
conversation that isn't all kind of
rainbows and roses right how do they
handle being interrupted for instance or
having someone interject right do they
do they keep their cool do they get
contracted they start to get reactive
so it doesn't have to be extreme
certainly to try to assess those things
are there any other names people who
come to mind
who you think are excellent at
navigating or thinking about risk i know
i keep bringing this up in part because
i just love learning of the case studies
it could be alive or dead
people you know people you don't know
but any other people who come to mind
for you there are the scholars who deal
with risk and i think you know
how we think daniel kahneman people like
that who've done a lot of thinking about
how the human mind thinks
i much prefer going to practitioners
who have dealt with very risky
situations and looked at how they
navigated them i would go and teach this
in my yale course abraham lincoln and
the emancipation proclamation
because when we step back
with
you know the distance of history
there was a wrong that was slavery there
was a civil war and in the middle of
that civil war the president united
states said okay
we're going to free the slaves
and
it was done and of course it wasn't at
all like that
right and so what president lincoln was
doing was dealing with risk he was
simultaneously dealing with
a civil war so the fact that they could
lose a civil war he's dealing with the
risk that
many people in
the democratic party of the north which
were not very supportive of bringing the
south to a you know a slave free
position
there were other stakeholders who
politically wanted to undermine him
there were foreign powers who really
weren't excited about the south not
being able to produce cotton like they
had and so he's trying to
triangulate or balance all of these
risks together
at the same time so it's not just
knowing what the right answer is
announcing the right answer and moving
forward
it is navigating
this twisted journey to as good an
answer as he could get not a perfect
answer but as good an answer as he could
get
and so when i look at that and i think
of
here's a leader who is having to assess
risk on a constant basis
he's got to keep his team together
you know his team of rivals on his
cabinet but also his his larger
national basis
and it was a masterful performance and
so
other than just being a smart guy and a
charismatic president
he was a master
manipulator is a negative word sometimes
but but that's what i'm really talking
about of orchestrating risk
yeah orchestrator excellent conductor of
risk factors
well stan we could go on for for many
hours i can't think of a better person
to
author risk a user's guide
are there any other facets of risk or
the book that you would like to
explore
or any other stories you'd like to tell
before we begin to come to a close in
this conversation sure i'm going to talk
on a personal basis here because i think
every leader
has to
identify how they deal with risks and
what their own value set are
i remember in 2006 i was leading
counter-terrorist forces in jsoc in iraq
and we had been at the fight for
at i had been at the fight for about
three years at that point most of the
the people as part of the task force had
been in even a little longer than that
and it was brutal
combat at the time
and so
we were starting to do operations more
aggressively than we'd ever done before
we were at a point where we were doing
literally 300 raids a month or 10 every
night and then occasionally we would
fight in broad daylight
and that was against our doctrine and it
didn't play to our strengths
and we had a situation where we got in a
firefight with al-qaeda forces outside
of baghdad and it became a real serious
fight and we put some what we call
little bird helicopter gunships into the
fight and one of those helicopters was
shot down
and the pilot killed
pilots in that particular case and
the father
of one of the people we lost had been a
aviator a helicopter pilot in vietnam
very mature very experienced guy
and he asked the question of us that was
fair he says what in the world was my
son out doing in the middle of daylight
flying a little helicopter that was
designed to be flown at night for
stealth
counter-terrorist missions
and
you know we answered him that's when the
fight was we needed him and he accepted
that very graciously
but the question we we had to ask
ourselves and and i did all the time is
at what point do you become hardened
to risk and the cost of risk
uh ulysses grant near the end of the
civil war wouldn't go to combat
hospitals he wouldn't visit the wounded
hospitals because he found it was so
upsetting
that he was afraid he couldn't make the
difficult decisions that he had to make
to get this war over
and i found
asking myself
whether
i'm becoming so hardened to the risk
because in some ways the risk physical
risk wasn't mine
it was being born by other people
and
had i become so close to the problem
that
solving this problem defeating al qaeda
in iraq was
overwhelming for me and what was the
risk to the larger you know national
policy and all that sort of thing
and it's almost like you are
you know that
you're in a bar with your brother and
you get in a fight and at a certain
point in the fight you need your brother
to pull you out of it
you may be losing you may be winning
either way you need your brother to pull
you out of it and uh i got four brothers
so you know that was very important but
i think we all need to think about risk
that way because there's a certain point
you're adrenaline pumps
your manhood gets challenged any number
of those things and
you will take risks and you'll bet
things that aren't yours to bet or you
will
stay the course
on things when you should have stopped
simply because
that's the way it is and so that's where
systems have to operate and they almost
have to at times to protect us against
ourselves
because we're we can be very good but
we're not always
as good at this as we need to be
sometimes we're just too human
yeah what will protect you what will
pull you out of the fight when you are
as we all are sometimes our lesser
selves
and systems are part of that answer
well stan thank you so much for taking
this time i think it's an important
couldn't be a timelier message and more
than a message it's a toolkit it's a
it's a set of frameworks and approaches
uh that have been tested in the field
and uh stress tested
so i i think this is an incredibly
important work
and
the book just to remind people the title
is risk user's guide you can find
general crystal online at
crystalgroup.com
his name is probably misspelled as often
as mine so i'll say it one more time
m-c-c-h-r-y-s-t-a-l-group.com i'll link
to all of these things everything we've
talked about in the show notes at
tim.log forward slash podcast
and
for everybody listening until next time
thank you for tuning in
you